here comes your starting pitcher jake
arienna starling martay has very good
numbers against jake arrieta was ball
one from jake arietta we are underway
and jazz a high chopper right side rizzo
they can't get it to first in time and
jazz will reach
not really a whole lot that rizzo or
arietta could do right there and jazz
aboard to start the day for the marlins
now slow developing play
on the right side you see rizzo
fumbled it maybe just a bit in the glove
was trying to catch and throw almost at
the same time arie had a got there but
jazz easily beats
the short toss
pitch from ariana there goes jazz throw
from low baton is
in time jazz disagrees marlins may want
to peek at it hoping for a quick start
to capitalize on the infield single mel
lobatone made up for lost time harry had
a very slow to the plate but a quick
release through from his knees i think
he's in there but that's just me yeah
where did sogard apply the tag would be
the question
now again the ruling on the field is out
so the marlins will need enough evidence
to overturn the call they are going to
ask for a challenge here the ruling on
this one again it was an out call of
jazz and he caught stealing
for loboton marlins believed that jazz's
left hand got in there before sogar the
second baseman applied the tag it looks
like we have our answer and jazz is in
there safely
maybe this is the angle into
double-digit steals now for jazz
and into scoring position for marte
starling ahead two balls no strikes and
grounds one left side backhanded by bias
and
safe at third brian dropping baseball he
got a little anxious himself trying to
apply the tag you know watch that's
probably the right play but baez you
know
makes a quick short throw to bryant it
hits him in the glove and he drops the
baseball that's on bryant that is not on
baez it was the right play all the
momentum was kind of leaning that way it
would have been a tough play at first
with martay and his speed
baez chooses to go to third bryant
dropped the baseball
two in scoring position now for aguilar
chopper to short baez has one play and
the marlins have one run rbi groundout
for aguilar his 50th ribby of the year
won nothing but the marlins have a first
inning run and they are looking for more
with marte having moved up and adam
duvall to the plate oh and two coming
and duvall hits one in the air right
field going back as hayward he turns and
looks and it's a home run for adam
duvall
he has done it again well don mattingly
says it best boy when he starts to heat
up it's usually quick and it's usually
productive you want to talk about a hot
hitter
how about an o2 pitch away yeah we've
seen that pull power from duvall all
season long but this is really
impressive 95 miles an hour two seam
action off the outside edge and a long
home run
to straight away
right field
stay hot out of duval stay hot for the
marlins it is pablo lopez his 15th start
of 2021 coming off his shortest start of
the season the loss to atlanta three
innings of work 39 pitches in that first
inning really had to work hard to get
through that inning three runs came in
to score
and it really unfortunately kind of set
off his entire outing he looks to bounce
back today here's the ball bounced past
pablo a jazz chisholm and thrown the
first for the out rizzo was
one for four with a double in last
night's game
and a ground ball diving play by jazz
and makes it look easy jazz chisholm jr
with a beautiful play to take a hit away
from rizzo three nothing after one
one on nobody out for john bertie count
is three and one
as birdie sends one out to center field
hat makes the catch alfaro tags here he
comes
and he's in there safely exactly fly for
john bertie do it dare i say
manufacturing another run the marlins
are up four nothing here in the second
pablo lopez the pitcher coming to the
plate
and a swing and a miss by pablo lopez
and that's the second out in the inning
strikeout for arietta his second of the
game two go on a run in and here is jazz
chisholm
ariana strikes out chisholm i think as
hot as adam duvall is right now if it's
got just a piece of the plate he might
hit it out
adam duvall not again not again
yes he did
he's on another planet right now wow
back to back two strike home runs for
adam duvall
my oh my
duval does it all my goodness a breaking
ball just talked about it with two
strikes and when he lays the bat down i
know he's got it i've got his home run
swing down when he does it it's almost
like we're all sitting here captivated
and a six to nothing lead for the
marlins on the power and the strength of
adam duvall bryant rizzo baez here in
the fourth inning two balls two strikes
here it comes from pablo
called strike three
seven on the corner well we've seen
pablo dial it up a couple of different
times today
i like this version of pablo to start
the fourth the strikeout of bryant at
97. struck out three of the last five
cubs that he's faced and with one out
here's rizzo two-two from pablo swing
and a miss 97 miles an hour
is he really dialing it up now rizzo
nearly takes him deep on 93-94 he says
okay fine here's 97 deal with that 29
strikeouts on the slider
he strikes out the side pablo lopez
looking great today as are the marlins
three balls in a strike on sanchez
and he skies this one near the mound
mass goes flying and it falls in and a
run comes in to score with two outs
duvall never stopped why would he
lobotone through the mass bryant was
coming in and no one ever
really took ownership of it seven
nothing applying constant pressure on
arietta abbott and the cubs all day
today lead off man on in each of the six
innings marlins have scored in five thus
far they're going to get another one
right here as it gets away from low
baton eight to nothing on the wild pitch
and the batter will be jesus sanchez
who's won for three on the day three and
two payoff pitch from brothers is lifted
out toward left field back and gone a
home run for jesus sanchez jesus sanchez
connects on a home run and the marlins
continue
with their offensive outburst in chicago
this weekend and the first major league
home run for the youngster now
congratulations to jesus sanchez my
goodness
birdie right field and caught by the
gold glover got a handful of them and he
makes a nice catch on that one no
problem
with the sun there on a low liner over
at first base jazz chisholm
when diaz gets resettled in the batters
box
play with diaz a high drive deep center
field this one is gone wow
way up on the batter's eye a huge home
run for lewin dia lewin welcome to the
party in wrigleyville my goodness
442 feet and the marlins scored their
11th runs in this game
jason hayward will bat with two down and
nobody on
hayward swings on the first pitch and he
drives the ball into the seats out into
left center and the cubs are on the
scoreboard against anthony bass a home
run for jason hayward his fifth of the
season and the second cub hit of the
afternoon here's jake mariznick loro
trying to finish this one off might do
just that birdie at third over to first
it's a marlins win they blow out the
cubs for the second straight day 10-2 on
friday 11-1 on saturday